just boy get started I do want to
mention another channel that I host it's
a new one it's called mega-projects it's
a channel all about mankind's greatest
achievements where I have a deep look at
things like incredible buildings project
structures and more whether it's the
world's most impressive skyscrapers the
International Space Station or Chernobyl
sarcophagus it's all covered on that
channel new videos come out a couple of
times a week on mega projects so if you
think it could be for you please do head
over there and subscribe there is a link
in the description below and let's get
into it
[Music]
in 1298
a manuscript was published that took
Western Europe by storm known today as
the travels of Marco Polo it detailed
the venetians adventures in Asia from
India to Japan to Sri Lanka impressive
as those tales were though it was the
figure at the heart of book 2 who really
set Europe and light the wise ancient
Emperor who ruled a China so wealthy so
enlightened that it seems like heaven on
earth sangre Emperor's name was Kublai
Khan founder of the Yuan Dynasty and
grandson of Genghis Khan he would go
down as one of the greatest rulers in
ancient history at the time of Marco
Polo's visit Kublai Khan sat at the head
of an empire so big that it defies
comprehension a Mongol warrior trains
from birth in the art of war hid
nonetheless grown into an emperor who
valued Buddhism science and progress
above conquest a towering figure in both
the Western and Chinese imagination this
is the story of Kublai Khan the Mongol
warrior who became a Chinese emperor
when you hear the name Kublai Khan we're
guessing you also here's the incredibly
famous opening of Samuel Taylor
Coleridge's poem in Xanadu did Kubla
Khan a stately pleasure-dome decree
aside from being to have the most famous
lines in English they also perfectly sum
up the Western vision of the Emperor a
semi-mythical aesthete living a life of
unparalleled elegance which means it can
come as a shock to realize Kublai Khan
wasn't born in a Grand Palace and didn't
spend his life spawning about in silk
pajamas know when Kublai first opened
his eyes on September the 23rd 12:15 the
sight that greeted him wasn't the
rarefied air of the Chinese imperial
court but the mud and din and savagery
of the Mongol Empire just nine years
earlier genghis khan had united the
rowdy drunk nomadic herders of the
Mongolian steppe into a rowdy drunk army
that was nevertheless one of the most
effective fighting units on earth
although the Empire's early days had
been marked by forward-thinking policies
like banning the kidnapping of women
that's progressivism had quickly given
way to conquest in 1209 Genghis Khan
invaded the neighboring shishya Kingdom
beginning the process that would lead to
his descendants controlling the largest
contiguous Empire in history by the time
Cabaye was born in 1215 Genghis at
flattens the shishya crushed the Jin
dynasty
and captured jong-du the city that would
now call Beijing we mentioned this
because Kublai wasn't just some random
kid born to some random Mongol comply
his father was Ptolemy the youngest son
of Genghis Khan well the youngest
legitimate son given that one in 200 men
today are direct descendants of Genghis
Khan we're guessing there were quite a
few illegitimate younger sons out there
now this didn't mean gooble I grew up
bouncing around on Genghis Khan's knee
as he conquered the world in fact Kublai
belli surahs grandpa Rory's father
instead he was mostly raised by his
mother the Christian princess saw Kotani
beki this meant a somewhat unusual
upbringing by Mongol standards for one
thing Sokka Thani was a ferociously
intelligent woman and talked Kublai and
his brother monkey to read at a time
when literacy came a dis
seconds to being able to bring down an
antelope for another she also made sure
to expose her boys to Chinese culture
and philosophy the impression this made
on Kublai was so great it would
eventually change the course of Asian
history still Kublai wasn't a pampered
little prince before he was Tony was a
formidable Horseman hunter and fighter
all things that Mongols need us if they
were to keep on conquering and
conquering was by now what the Mongols
were all about when Kublai was just five
the Central Asian cuisine Empire made
the fatal mistake of insulting Genghis
Khan by the time Kublai was ten that
Empire had fallen leaving the Mongols in
charge of an empire that stretched from
the Sea of Japan to the Caspian Sea
a distance similar to that separating
Memphis Tennessee
from Honolulu little did young Hugh
blind know but that Empire was about to
fall into his family's hands on August
the 18th 1227 Genghis Khan died of
injuries sustained while falling off a
horse in the aftermath of the Great
Khans death control of the Empire
briefly passed to who buys father
Tyler II it was the family's first brush
with immense power and it certainly
wouldn't be their last
in the wake of Genghis Khan's death the
Kurata great gathering of Mongol leaders
was cold though the decision was made
that toy we should hand control of the
Empire over to Genghis as other son
Agha died this was something of a weird
choice Agha died was a guy so dedicated
to drunkenness that when other mongol
leaders ordered him to cut down to just
three cups of wine a day he started
drinking from cups roughly the size of
bathtubs he also had no practical
experience of conquering Watauga died
did have though was an ability to
delegate his view of the Empire was this
you can conquer an empire on horseback
but you cannot govern it on horseback
so while great generals like Suba time
were sent West to keep conquering anyone
with a more civilized Benz of mind
stayed home to keep things in order
it was this philosophy that led to
Kublai getting his first practical
experience of ruling in 1236 Agha died
granted Kublai a fiefdom of 10,000 homes
in modern high-bay at first the 21-year
old line was like this is pretty boring
he ignored his duties sending agents to
do all of the burdens and stuff like
collecting taxes unfortunately these
agents were exactly as competent as you
would expect a bunch of Mongol Raiders
to be and the twin threats of Taxation
and terror soon left Cuba lies province
almost empty it was only at the end of
the decades that auger diet seems to
have told Kublai dude get that province
in order or lose it and Kublai finally
started taking acting like a ruler
seriously but while the role may have
been forced upon him there's no doubt
that he excelled at it with comply now
on the scene all those incompetent tax
collectors were fired and replaced by
experienced Chinese officials at the
same time Qi began consulting Chinese
advisers more and more although they
were just a part of his local court a
court that included Christians and
Muslims as well they soon edged the
other voices out it seems that Kublai
just couldn't get over his childhood
fascination with all things Chinese for
the other Mongols this was shocking
who would voluntarily exchange manling
mongol traditions like hunting and
fighting for wisi chinese ones like tea
and reading but Kublai wasn't
about to be deterred he became
interested in Buddhism again to
appreciate Confucianism including the
revolutionary idea that the well-being
of an empires subjects was just as
important as that of its rulers still
these interests seemed laughably
irrelevant to other Mongols the Empire
was currently pushing into Europe the
Unconquered south of China forgotten
about what need would the Mongols have
for pretentious Chinese guff now well
yes about that on December the 11th 1241
Agha died died of a stroke at that
precise moment the Mongols were laying
waste to Eastern Europe Kiev had been
sacked Krakow / to the sword and raiding
parties were knocking at the gates of
Vienna then word arrived of organized
death and the conquerors simply turned
around and went home at least that's the
story some historians think the retreat
was sounded for other reasons and Agha
dies death was just a convenient excuse
whatever the truth the upshot was that
Europe was forgotten about well of a
messy issue of organized successor
always sorted out after a few years of
quarreling it was eventually decided
that coup Bligh's alder brother
monkey should be the Great Khan as
monkey it was a guy as obsessed with
China as Kublai was from now on the
Mongol focus wasn't gonna be on
rampaging further and further into
Europe but on conquering the last
independent parts of China no sooner had
monkey been declared Great Khan than he
gave Kublai two very important things
one was northern China yep the Mongol
Empire in 1251 was so vast the monkey
could basically gift half of China to
his brother and say hope you like it the
second was an order one designed to test
coop lies metal monkey wanted Qi to
conquer the Dali Kingdom at this point
Kublai had never run a military campaign
and there was no guarantee he wouldn't
turn out to be the Mongol equivalent of
mr. bean it took comply a whole year to
prepare to fight the Dali a whole year
in which he practiced tactics and read
great Chinese thinkers on the arts of
war finally in 1253 comply saddled up
God his army together and rode
into the dolly kingdom the conquest took
three years but it wasn't three years
marked by the usual Mongol atrocities
Kublai now firmly believed what his
Chinese advisers had taught him about
her rulers codependence with the ruled
this meant not killing new subjects
during conquest but treating them with
mercy for the Mongols this was seriously
cuckoo stuff like if a modern general
suggested that his army tried replacing
its bullets with Black Forest gateau
but Kublai was serious Tara was to be
toned down and pillaging when I was out
and so a new era of Mongol warfare began
by 12:56 the Dali Kingdom had fallen
buoyed by his brothers success bonkie
began planning an invasion of southern
China where the Song Dynasty still held
out but such an undertaking required
time time in which Kublai wasn't just
gonna park his thumb up his ass and wait
for his brother to say go so people I
left Dali and returns north to embark on
his most famous project of all Xanadu is
legendary in the english-speaking world
although this is mostly due to Courreges
poem it deserves the hype complies new
capital was designed on Chinese
principles of Feng Shui perfectly placed
in relation to mountains and rivers
between the agricultural lowlands and
Mongolian steppe great walls and towers
enclosed a city of 200,000 people all
laid out on a classic Chinese Square
plan at its heart SATA palace almost
beyond imagination a stately
pleasure-dome complete with its own
hunting grounds it was an expression of
complies love for Chinese style but also
of his power power that was growing by
the minute
in 1258 comply invited leaders of both
Buddhist thought and Taoism to Xanadu
for a great religious debate there he
listened to both sides before eventually
declaring that Buddhism had one making
it northern China's official religion it
was a decision that would play a huge
part in Buddhism spread across East Asia
but as Kublai's stature grew monkey
began taking notice the same year as the
religious debate he sent agents to
Xanadu who began purging Kublai's
Chinese advisors on trumped-up charges
for a moment
it looked like there could be a civil
war between
brothers but monkey backs off at the
last moment realizing he needed his
brother for the upcoming fight against
the song they patched things up and in
1259 they finally invaded southern China
sadly though the civil war hadn't been
stopped it would now just take place
between different siblings an August the
11th monkey died while besieging a song
city immediately to candidates for his
successor presented themselves up in
Mongolia proper Cuba lies younger
brother Erik Bose was at the head of a
conservative faction displeased with
monkeys China war down in the South
there was Kublai even now fighting the
war his brother had so long dreamed of
there was only one way a Khan could ever
be chosen between two siblings they were
going to have to fight
[Music]
if anyone ever had any doubts about
cublas ambitions they were quickly
dispelled after Monkees death as soon as
he could Cabaye made a peace treaty with
the song then he marched quickly back up
north to Xanadu and on May the 5th 1260
he calls a curette I it ended with Q
Bligh being elected Great Khan and a
proclamation drawn up in classical
Chinese but while complies meeting named
him leader this wasn't the same as him
actually leading the Mongols up in
Karakoram Eric Berger responded to the
news by essentially going oh yeah and
then he hold a design guru tie which
named him the Great Khan it was a
stalemate goodbye now controlled the
biggest richest part of the mbar while
eric boe ruled the homelands it's
arguable that this stalemate was never
really resolved although could blind
defeated art Burgess forces in 1264 the
north of the Empire remains out of his
control the conservative faction
replaced our bows with a guy called Kai
do and I do basically did his own thing
like he was separate from Cuba lies
Empire it's around this point that we
can stop thinking of the Mongol Empire
as a single entity and more like the
collection of car notes that would
eventually become still nominal control
of the homelands it was good enough it
could lie our Igbo defeated he went
straight back to war with the Song
Dynasty there was a hell of a fight
although only in control of southern
China the song could still call up an
army of a million men they had gunpowder
catapults siege engines a navy with the
biggest ships in human history it was a
fire to kill I had no guarantee he would
win so why did he bother while the
reason was simple
Cabaye didn't want to make the song
submit he wanted to reunify China prior
to Kublai Khan the last time China had
been unified had been under the Tang
Dynasty you'd fallen 360 years before to
give you some idea of how ridiculously
long ago that was traveling back in time
360 years from today would land you in
1660 in 1660 Oliver Cromwell had only
just died
New York was still New Amsterdam louis
xiv
was still on the French throne Ghibli's
dream of reuniting China was like you
meeting someone too
who dreams of returning the 13 colonies
to England it was mad it was laughable
but it was also something he totally
succeeded at by 1271 qibla he had
established a new capital in modern-day
Beijing and renamed his empire in the
Chinese style declaring it the yuan
dynasty by the mid twelve 70s song
generals were defecting swearing
allegiance to the new yuan Emperor at
last on March the 28th 1276 the boy
emperor of the song was captured and
taken as prisoner to Beijing although
song loyalists would fight on for three
more years their writing was on the wall
the final end came on March the 19th
1279 on that day a titanic naval battle
took place near modern Macau when it was
finally over there was no one left to
oppose could like on aged 63 the great
Carnot at last finished his brothers
work China was now conquered reunified
and at the mercy of the Mongols only the
other Mongols didn't quite see it that
way in the course of the conquest
complies Yuan Dynasty had begun to take
on more and more Chinese characteristics
until it seems completely alien no one
knew what was coming next but they may
have agreed on one thing whatever form
yuan rule took it certainly wasn't going
to be Mongol in nature
[Music]
in 1275 three bedraggled men arrived at
Kublai Khan's vast Marwar palace they
came from the distant city of Venice
over 7500 kilometers away the older two
were merchants while the younger was a
lad of barely twenty with gift for
languages they'd come intending to stay
only for a short while but when calm saw
them he was so impressed with the
youngest that he made them stay for
sixteen whole years the name of that
young man was as you've probably already
guessed Marco Polo and it's his account
of complies court that still forms the
basis of how we see the Yuan Dynasty by
the time Polo presented himself to the
Great Khan the growing Empire was
already in full swing under the yuan
China entered a period of incredible
prosperity but one that wasn't quite the
uncomplicated picture of perfection that
polo painted on the good side comply it
was a ruler who was seriously into
innovation under his watch everything
from an empire-wide postal service to
the issuing of paper money was
established that you on China wasn't
just about physical improvements Kublai
was also a leader in innovative thinking
freedom of religion was embraced many
language from around the Empire was
permitted at court and hue bliley even
hired a team to create an artificial
language which would bind his subjects
together although this never caught on
there was scientific advances to comply
had accurate maps made of China are
established Institutes of Medicine and
improved the calendar he also turns
Chinese society on its head under the
song artisans and doctors had been
discriminated against as useless idiots
who spent their time doing stuff with
their hands rather than refining their
minds with Confucian poetry but Kublai
flips that he handed artisans enormous
tax breaks promoted doctors and
astronomers the result was an economic
boom hooked dragged reunified China into
the new era the complies outward
successes masked some of his deeper
failures one was a state policy of
racial discrimination while Kublai
played the part of the Chinese emperor
wearing traditional robes and allowing
himself to be carried around by servants
the reality was that his China was
deeply discriminatory towards Chinese
the yuan had four social classes at the
top were Mongols who held all of the key
posts seconds were useful
foreigners like Marco Polo or the cons
MERS and treasurers thirds were northern
Chinese who shouldered a heavy tax
burdened forth were the southern Chinese
who were considered lower than vermin
the result was millions of Chinese
crushed by taxes and treated like
strangers in their own lands on a
personal level to Kublai it wasn't quite
the serene emperor of popular
imagination the Khan drank like a fish
ate like a pig and screwed like a rabbit
the result was that he eventually
transformed into a fat gout ridden horny
blob prone to outbursts of temper and
yet for all these faults there's no
doubting koop lies legacy in Chinese
official historiography the yuan era is
regarded not as an interregnum but as
part of the Imperial story and honor
only afforded to one other foreign
dynasty the ching but what occupies rule
at home might be complicated there's no
such shades of grey regarding his
foreign policy that's because his time
as Emperor was taken up not with being a
great administrator a powerful warrior
or even a champion drunk but with an
endless series of disastrous Wars
[Music]
while the most interesting things about
cube lie is that there always seems to
have been two people in his head
fighting for control one was Q Bligh
the yuan emperor who wanted nothing more
than to follow his childhood obsession
with all things Chinese and settle down
as a wise ruler
the other was Kublai Khan the Mongol
warrior who felt his life should be
taken up with conquest sadly for kube
lies prosperity in his later years it
was Qi the warrior who won out we say
sadly because despite his early life
victories against the Dali the song and
Erik Bo's later life Kublai was a real
putz when it came to conquering there
were his two invasions of Japan in 1274
and 1281 which both times resulted in
typhoons wrecking his entire Navy an
incident which led to the Japanese
concept of the Divine Wind or kamikaze
there were his two invasions of Vietnam
and his two invasions of Burma both of
which resulted in Pyrrhic victories
thanks to their sheer insane cost
finally there was Cuba lies 1292
invasion of Java which ended with the
victorious Mongols so riddled with
disease that they were forced to retreat
after a single year it was a
disappointing end to a dizzying career
like a rollercoaster rides that reaches
its highest peak only to suddenly shut
down and leave you disappointed but it's
likely that by the time of the Java
disaster Kublai no longer cared in 1281
and 1285 the yuan emperor had lost his
favorite wife and then his eldest son
this one-two punch of tragedy seems to a
flaw Kublai who withdrew from the
day-to-day running of the Empire instead
drowning his sorrows in drinking and
feasting by the time he finally allowed
Marco Polo to leave his court
the one-time warrior was nothing but a
fat unhappy man trapped in a vast palace
as luxurious as it was empty
Qi Khan finally died on February the
18th 1290 for his body was buried in a
secret place somewhere in Mongolia as
with his grandfather Genghis Khan his
remains have never been found in the
years after he buys death two important
things happened that would ensure his
place in history the first was that
Marco Polo's book appeared forever
fixing an image of the Khan as a wise
and
Rula ii was the collapse of the Yuan
Dynasty
although Kublai's descendants ruled
China peacefully for 30 years in 1320
for a series of uprisings marked the
beginning of the dynasty's decline come
1368 the yuan was so weak that the ming
were able to conquer China and establish
their own dynasty in the aftermath the
Mongols retreated back to the steppe
never again playing an important part in
history but the same can't be said of
Kublai Khan in 1644 the Ming in turn
fell to Manchu invaders the king as the
new masters of China that Ching looked
back to the last foreign dynasty as
their inspiration as the Golden Age they
hope to emulate in the story of Kublai
Khan
they found the template for their own
dynasty a dynasty that would last until
1911 today ku Blinds name still survives
less as that of a historic figure and
more as a byword for something romantic
poetic and mystical yes this is more
than that afforded to any other Mongol
leader
apart from Genghis Khan more even than
perhaps any other Chinese Emperor Kublai
Khan the man may be long dead but the
stories of his exploits the influence
his life had on others ensure that his
name will live on forever so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below don't forget to subscribe
if you like more from me please do check
out that channel I mentioned at the
beginning mega projects I'm gonna link
to that below please do check it out
subscribe if you want to and thank you
for watching
[Music]